there was a really interesting anime
event that happened up out there in
poland i want to show preach
[Music]
so this was an mma fight in poland it
was an intergender mma fight
all over the world mma fans were
disgusted so ula siekie x lost
his name is moaboy
yo did she just charging like a bull i
could hit you with my legs
i could use you with this but guess what
else i can do
[Laughter]
hey man when i used to watch spider-man
one right rhino was one of my favorite
villains and that was a beautiful homage
a beautiful homage shout out to her
[Music]
man that [ __ ] look illegal bro
that looked like a crime
that looked like a crime
[Music]
i'm sorry if you get real if you get
beat up by nick one hm
if the [ __ ] beating you up
look at the flick of the wrist if he
does this [ __ ]
if he does this
okay if he knows a little beyonce head
flick
okay
oh my god that was actual makeup
oh
he said [ __ ] just because i'm gay
fabulous don't mean i can't get down and
dirty
oh my god look at me i lost two pounds
yes [ __ ] queens yo
bro
so what are your thoughts
i want to puke
yeah oh yeah that means you're sick that
made me sick really why
it's not the sport
it's it's not the sport it's not what it
is
it's just pure buffoonery
you know i mean there's no technique
it's nothing it's not about
nothing it's not about none of what this
is
what this game is you know i mean it's
not what it is it's not it's not it's
nothing
it's nothing
pure
that's what it is it makes me sick
it's a real thing it's a real game
and then that
what's the why
why
[ __ ] why
why i'm not gonna lie to you man
there's probably a bunch of mma fights
happening all over the world and i
really don't give a [ __ ]
but i was curious when i heard about
this
it's a freak show
sometimes people want to watch a freak
show sure i didn't open this up thinking
i'm going to watch some high quality mma
i said
let's go to the circus today where is
this i like the circus the fair's in
town [ __ ] do you want to see a clown
get dumped in a pool of water you might
be saying why but that's what the fair
is for i go to the fair to go why
why [ __ ] here's twenty dollars do it
again oh the monkey's gonna eat some
peanuts i wanna watch that
i wanna see a delusional girl get
slapped up by a femme boy yeah
i actually do want to see that you know
what i want to see what you want to see
i want to see
james charles [ __ ] up tatiana i want to
watch that i do i want to see them go in
the ring i want to see what happens you
know instead of all this [ __ ] makeup
drama what happens if we both gave him
some lip gloss and said [ __ ] do
whatever y'all want each other next time
yes
don't you want to see that do you want
to watch a little bit of a freak show
can you when i watch flame floyd
mayweather versus conor mcgregor that
was a freak show too
can you roll the clip back and just go
to when albert says i like the circus he
said it like the dude that says i like
booty
i like the circus
and i'm gonna have you now we can do
this the easy way or we can do this the
hard way but i'm gonna have some circus
i'm talking to girls like that on the
right
cause like how do you feel about me i
like you i know
go ahead what else do you say
i start with that yeah did you stop when
you keep on going well it depends
[Music]
if
i'm just trying to [ __ ] if i'm just
trying to [ __ ] i'll be like i like you
and i want you and i'm gonna have some
booty
now if i'm serious about that i'm like i
want your booty forever it's a bit
different okay but you don't go we could
do this the hardware the easy because
that sounds radiant no no no that's too
far that's so far that's too far too far
flag on them but uh flag on the plane by
black flag or flow
flanking flower
flagrant flower that was
that was
gay that that
that was super sustainable
you know she was interviewed after the
fight and expressed her disappointment
the result i was very dissatisfied it
didn't work out as i wanted i'm
disappointed in myself
unfortunately for now i'll have these
negative emotions
i am surprised that the referee stopped
the fight because i had more hits before
and i could withstand though so i think
the third round could easily happen
she said there should have been a third
round
you mean with this
what the [ __ ] you mean
what do you mean
bro no i'm waiting for interesting
interesting suggestions i will continue
to develop
uh what doesn't kill us makes us
stronger
yes
why
even if you're the guy in that position
and they tell you
if you lose you got nothing to win this
is a lose-lose situation for the guy if
you lose you got beat by a girl if you
win you beat up a girl you can't win
as a guy you can't win i don't know
about that pretty there's a bunch of
dudes out there who wouldn't mind
knocking out a [ __ ]
that's not what i'm saying but to the
public
it's not always about the public
it's like masturbating
sometimes it just feels good to you
does he not are you you're just saying
you're advocating for beating women no
i'm just saying you said there's no
winning i'm saying for this guy
look at this man he's clearly excited to
do this crazy [ __ ] had [ __ ]
uh superhero paint on his face okay this
is not like he was evangelical he was
avenging something when he went into
full mouth he didn't look reluctant he
said i have some punches for you [ __ ]
i'm not getting i'm getting a contract
that's crazy you thought my makeup was
[ __ ] up
that's the interesting thing about this
promotion i think they were going this
for shock factor it brought a lot of
views to them and honestly when you come
from countries like that you're probably
just trying to make a quick buck off
this [ __ ] is it good for the sport no is
it absolutely terrible what happened yes
because at the end of the day
fights like that shouldn't happen you're
putting someone's actual health in
danger but if you're just asking me as a
viewer who just wants a few laughs i'm
not gonna lie i watched that [ __ ] and
that was funny
that was funny that was it was i got it
man it was the best doing a little rhino
dance yeah yeah butt thing yeah there's
a couple times where she got hit in the
face and she's like oh this is what it
feels like you could tell she's not used
to being pow oh wow [ __ ] whoa okay um
[ __ ] yeah i mean i'm not gonna go
laughing you know what i mean
the two he went for he i think he might
have taken a class or two
my suspicion
the way he went from side mount to full
mount wasn't completely amateurish
sorry let me first it was completely
amateurish but she had no experience
whatsoever no she didn't know what the
phone was yeah yeah yeah yeah so shout
out to him you know what i'm saying that
was super funny
just all the way she pushed him in the
press conference
yeah why mm-hmm
yeah cause she's seen other people do
that [ __ ] dude
hey man there's money to be made like i
said you're gonna see more of these
freak shows if you guys are outraged by
this i promise you cripples are coming
okay
yes [ __ ] are wheelchairs they're gonna
be fighting videos
small people
yeah i i want to see hezbollah fight
yeah yeah
i want to see him fight was it was a
mahmoud what's the other one saying
another small dude
he's famous too he makes music yeah yeah
some girl sent me the song what the [ __ ]
is this
same thing i was like what the [ __ ] yeah
all this to say
this is just the beginning freak shows
can't get it
you guys have seen the way a reality tv
show was gone you got the youtube boxing
you got a bunch of amateurs descending
beasts and boxing rings this is
inevitable inevitable so
um let us know what you guys think in
the comments below we want to hear from
you